las primeras conversaciones diplomáticas
de alto nivel desde el comienzo de la
guerra concluyeron con poco consenso ni
medidas concretas que pongan fin al
derramamiento de sangre en ucrania el
ministro de asuntos de exteriores de
ucrania dmitro el culé va se reunió con
su homólogo ruso serguéi lávrov en
turquía el jueves en una reunión mediana
a por ankara la situación de mariupol es
lo prioritario para los ucranianos
quienes reclaman un corredor humanitario
que permite el paso seguro de los
civiles y de los suministros médicos
lamentablemente el ministro lávrov no
estaba en condiciones de comprometerse a
ello pero se pondrá en contacto con las
autoridades respectivas sobre esta
situación
y
también planteamos un alto el fuego por
24 horas para resolver las cuestiones
humanitarias más acuciantes
pero no hubo avances ya que parece que
hay otras personas encargadas de este
asunto en rusia we did not make progress
son des gens
y
puedes meter en razón de hecho estos
encargos fueron señalados por lávrov que
aplazó muchas de las cuestiones
planteadas en antalya dirigiéndolas en
cambio al ciclo de conversaciones de un
curso en belarús que es un aliado de
rusia en cuanto a la situación de
ucrania labró parecía más preocupado por
la injerencia extranjera que por el
propio papel de moscú en los recientes
ataques a
[Música]
aquellos que siguen equipando ucrania de
armas deben entender la responsabilidad
de sus actos
esto es igualmente para aquellos que
quieren enviar mercenarios los llamados
batallones a ucrania para luchar en el
espíritu de las tradiciones introducidas
por las fuerzas ultra radicales en la
vida cotidiana de ucrania
hubo un punto en el que ambas partes
estuvieron de acuerdo que los diálogos
podían y debían continuar puleva reiteró
que quiere que las conversaciones
continúen y lávrov señaló que vladimir
putin no se negaría a reunirse con
volodymyr selenski aunque eso dependería
de los avances en el marco diplomático
en belarús